[Music]
the more I can do we know you're a
person that is all about good deals
what's been your biggest lurch because I
know recently your mom has been released
and you said how proud she is of you
have you splurged on her yet
yeah well I got an apartment for I got
it a best psychiatrist the best nurses
best meal plans like a nutrition is my
grandma like I spend almost $30,000 a
month on both of them to get them the
best nurses like the best every I spend
a lot of money I feel like with somebody
might make in a year
on just the two of them that's beautiful
and then I just and then I buy myself a
unicorn necklace I should have worn that
tonight I bought myself a unicorn
necklace and I wanna wear it because I
want to get it dirty because it's more
than it's more than a thousand dollars
the first blow-up they tend to take a
lot of different roles are you getting
pickier now that time is going on and
everyone knows tiffany had his name I've
been pinky from day one I only do the
roles that resonate with my spirit like
when it makes me feel good I'll do it I
had I have taken on some roads earlier
in my credit that I wasn't like I didn't
know what resonated me I didn't know
what really sparked me but since I did
just Jordan everything that I've done
has made me feel confident and what I
have to give the world
[Music]
[Applause]